yeah yeah yeah yeah that's always my
favorite when the show porn cutting
where they go and the lights are down
and they're light and they get like one
or two more like yeah
they stop there they go and we're up and
rolling you guys go to that was that a
toy there was a series that was free I
saw it for free I don't know four
networks or whatever online but it's uh
people trying out for porno I'm being
like Retief yes it's a real world style
though they all live in the place so
they have a drama so they sabotage
her and she's laying there like
[Music]
sabotage that she's she goes and
she goes she's like he's like survivor
style to me and this is what he gets
yes absolutely on these generic things
like party bus come shots
whoa what does that even mean it's
their videos are people on party
buses and they shoot come on these other
girls there you go probably this is
great it's great it is just super jerko
it's a million dollar porn competition
come on guys we're past it
what's the but you meet them all at
first and it's like real reality this
might be the only thing that can get you
to watch a whole porn these days you're
like I'll tell you what I've watched at
least a minute of every episode what's
playing with the pros play with the pros
do they get to a seasoned yes dude
that's great they say what the black guy
can't come and the one thing I saw it's
not point it's not as easy as people
think
now you it's a it's an actual dude
that's on there it's not you don't have
to be the main dude you can be a start
dude you can you could be a start penis
it's time yeah well you just stand there
and when a dude can't get it up
you gotta go in and pound it today tell
you to come out is there a lady with a
headset in the clipboard going soft
again smoking a cigarette they go dawn
someone get the truck going because you
know it's like he's a dude trying out
and people are watching him okay I've
set up with a porn star yeah okay all
right this is early on I don't know she
was a star
she was a poem person dicey film
I wouldn't use your social she she
literally she has movies her name is
hazel eyes oh like a um I met her in
Shreveport Louisiana yep Shreveport
Louisiana are you so levels and and
what's crazy how do we jump into a light
lightweight little relationship it
wasn't like because it was it the the
sex was so good and it was so amazing to
you that you're like I got a key I gotta
keep coming back did she told me not to
watch her movies you know okay I I'm way
past that
I know you are waitressing right now I'm
the one to say that's gotta be where she
goes okay so you have the chicken parm
and I'm gonna bring you and you go are
you hazel I wasn't sure
yes we went to Waffle House no with the
I hop in Bossier City which is right
across which is right across where you
take him and don't make your bacon a
smile food that gives me emotion I met
another chick that was a porn star we
went we went out to Papa toes okay
Houston um she I think she was engaged
to Wesley Pipes really just talking
about Wesley Park yeah yeah I think she
was engaged to Wesley Pike cuz she I
thought that he had two guns
he grabs his dick in the ones I have two
dogs waffle to each other prizes the
mote it has to be the most most
ridiculous porn man he says the mote I'm
sorry I wouldn't if I was a poor lady
I've let you know I'm I don't want him
rocco siffredi is pretty bad yeah well
he all blues like half Europeans he's
like oh you have to put his foot in your
head in a toilet he was always my
favorite because he was the most like
punk rock 1 2 3
he liked power chords I think I could be
with a chick who was was in porn yeah I
could we're not currently in porn no no
not good you'd have to be otherwise you
had to be now guys I can't be dating a
bank robber it's gotta be out of the
public it's gotta be out of the public
eye I mean everybody's only watching
classic clips you never really go back
you never who's buying the new stuff I
don't want to look like is there even a
new release section yeah there is but no
one's checking it out you only want the
stuff from here there's a lot of people
out there putting good product watching
hard browsers he's bigger than ever
[Music]